de la laine du bois de l'ardoisé ou
encore de la céramique
tous les matériaux peuvent être utilisés
pour former des motifs ou des figures la
mosaïque est un art ancestral bien
vivant cette exposition le prouve
je trouve qu'il ya une démarche de 2,2
d'imaginaire d'imagination et sachons
simplement extraordinaire parce qu'il ya
autant de mosaïste autant de styles
différents autant de façons d'exprimer
différentes autant de pauses de
techniques différentes
c'est une richesse incroyable quoi on
prend son pied
malgré la pandémie l'association 3r a
réussi à rassembler quelques 150 oeuvres
dont certaines viennent du japon de
russie ou des états unis et aux côtés
des amateurs il y à des grands noms de
la musique contemporaine
alors c'est une oeuvre réalisée par
marco di luca qui vit et travaille à
ravenne sur cette oeuvre signe de ses
dernières compositions le support et du
papier est en fait dans son esprit
philosophique il a enfermé le savoir qui
était écrit un journal dans cet avant
ravenne ville italienne jumelée à
chartres capitale de la musique
contemporaine où cet art est reconnue
célébrer alors qu'en france aucun musée
ne possède de mosaïques réalisées ces 50
dernières années
et pourtant les passionnés existe on a
suivi jean marie dans son atelier je
sors les crayons une feuille de papier
je commence à dresser ce que va être le
projet il peut rester ensuite en
gestation pendant deux jours où pendant
trois mois et ensuite je passe à
l'exécution de la taille des pièces qui
vont constituer cette oeuvre
celle ci c'est pour un projet pour 2021
avec ses oeuvres rouge intense il espère
attirer l'oeil du public faire savoir au
plus grand nombre qu'on peut posséder
une mosaïque comme on achète un tableau
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mosaïque de
chevalet